[Music]
[Music]
is Hannibal Burres you listen to the
handsome ramble the podcast number what
people were asking me why do you have a
podcast nap why so late is never too
late it's never too late for now I
figured everybody else get one I got
access to microphones and bandwidth and
the ability to put things up on iTunes
SoundCloud in other audio mediums why
not me
I got I have a great voice and there's
some people out there that may never see
me live this is the this is what they
can get so this is this podcast is for
you fan listening in Madagascar you know
probably not gonna tour they're probably
not doing gigs in Madagascar what it's
podcast the handsome ramble oh why do I
have a podcast it is because why not man
why not I've seen all these people
change their lives or they use it as
therapy or they just get to work on
their voices feel unfiltered thoughts
get in all access look until your
comedian psyche
well maybe I'll play characters what if
I do it like it's an old-timey radio
show you don't know what I'm capable of
when I'm left to my own devices with a
microphone it's different a different
time now
comedians used to try to give radio jobs
if some still do you try to get on
radio station and now everybody's just I
can do my own radio station so I wanted
to be a part of it man
plus I'm trying to you know read that ad
copy for bevel who's the other ones this
is the milling company stamps stamps at
home and some shaving and go check out
movies Gamefly I want to read that stuff
check me out gift cards dot gift cards
go to gifts art here's my audition to
read ad copy go to gift cards that gift
cards where know you are you tired of
when your gift card you are you try to
just give the gift card and then having
to give somebody a gift card we'll go to
gift cards like gift cards will give
card to give card to the gift card get
20% off your first order with the code
Rambler that's like that's a good idea
give cards for gift cards yeah gift card
gift card well we give a gift card for
your gift card no more gift cards for
you so yeah I decided to try it out and
as I saw what it look at what it's done
for Bill burr he does his podcast he's
be selling out shows in Slovenia and
good for him and it's just him most of
the time just talking you know how many
things you have to have going on in your
mind to just talk straight up I'm
already ready to in this podcast maybe
they had the 3 minute podcast already uh
and I don't want to interview my friends
I don't want to interview I don't want
to be that a man come do my podcast I
don't want to ask people to do the
podcast all the time that's what some
people some people told me they quit
their podcast cuz it got tired of asking
people to do their podcast this booking
is tough
that's where Bill Byrne
it's just him is this is this a podcast
about podcasts is it the podcast about
nothing
we're just we talk about podcasts no got
others [ __ ] to talk about no no did I
just lose sponsors by saying [ __ ] huh we
at give cars not give cars have with
John our sponsorship of the handsome RAM
of the podcast we had a Hannibal say
[ __ ] and we don't those doesn't
represent our values you over here at
give cards like gift cards we wish
Hannibal further success in his career
and endeavors do people people never say
endeavors always somebody else's right
and endeavors net by definition but
that's the way we use the word is what
I'm saying
well it could be yours like I'm going on
an endeavor no people is say good luck
with your endeavors his endeavors you
know that my endeavors it sounds too
grandiose like it being cocky like I'm
about to go endeavors you gonna be a
part of my endeavors but oh you gotta
check out his your endeavors but it's
it's an attempt to achieve a goal I know
an endeavor to reduce serious injury no
maybe I'm just making up stuff about
words usually endeavors you wish you the
best
good luck in your future endeavors it's
usually used like that like kind of like
you you don't care about my future
endeavors
nobody ever says it it's never
possessive really I don't know you know
you could use it as a word like you're
in can you use it as endeavouring as a
verb yeah endeavoring I'm endeavoring to
be a podcaster I'm endeavoring to be a
podcaster
I'm endeavoring to take my career to the
next lateral movement you are
endeavoring to get your ticket sales up
I'm endeavoring to be the best actor of
my generation sometimes I watch movies
or television and then I'll see you
actor doing an eyebrow thing or a facial
twitch or tick and I say whoo I'm gonna
use that but then I never use it it's
it's important they have good eyebrow
technique it is well but I'm saying I
see these great moves from actors and I
think I'm gonna remember them
that's tough to remember I can't just
it's a lot of pressure to put on my
brain a brain remember hey remember when
Tyrese kind of smile but grimace at the
same time put that in your repertoire
and I say yeah I'm gonna do that next
time I'm on camera if it fits the
situation but you ever just like
practice in front of the mirror so I'm
like facial expressions yeah just like
in the mirror like look at these
eyebrows at work no no I know what I
used it before I became a comedian I was
it was some rope but I was just being a
mirror sometime like yeah just do it in
the mirror just perform it it was before
I I mean it was obvious that I needed to
be a comedian but I didn't know it yet
but I was making weird faces in the
mirror making noises in my dorm room I
do remember that yeah all you need to
give back to your roots man start doing
the X amount mirror looking roots oh oh
man back here in Chicago chillin in
Logan Square I was coming - oh that was
going through the the back entrance
of Tony's apartment building and I'm
walking and bout to walk up the steps
and your neighbor your neighbors is cat
can I help you soon even live in the
same building
no she's live in the next building your
buildings got different owners correct
yeah and they're detached or not
connects hatch builders I'm walking up
these steps not even well the steps just
yet can I help you you know I was kind
of in the zone so I was thinking about
something now and he's in and look over
it he said can I help you and I just
said no mm-hmm no you can't you can't
help me because he couldn't yeah but
that's not the answer see what I knew
where I was going
I've been there several times before and
she yes you can I help you cuz they want
to take it oh I'm alright explains [ __ ]
to you no you can't help me
let's go Oh some people were sitting on
the bonus tab set that I got [ __ ] to do
with me shut up same thing happened at
the zany's in Nashville a few months
back they got the side door where that
leads to the green room
and so I woke up to it and I'm knocking
I try to open the door first as lot and
I'm knocking on a door and the guy is
the security guard for the parking lot
about 20 30 feet away and I'm not gonna
do it can I help you not to say no you
can't what well most people will say
like no I'm okay but I like I'm gonna
start using that no can't help me no the
person who can help me is on the other
side of the door you can't help me you
know you out here doing outside [ __ ] I'm
trying to do inside [ __ ]
you can't help me leave me alone
can I help you no the person I'm not
getting that far as it can help me the
person who hears my knock
you can help me stop talking to me
please you're making me uncomfortable
walked up on me and [ __ ] I'm just trying
to get outta you get help you get help
by minding your business gonna help
by minding your [ __ ] [ __ ] can
you help me yeah do you have an adderall
in a cialis then you can help me say
that yeah that's nice sure sure you got
some adderall or C can you help me sure
I got this tenant that is really pissing
me off
oh man so yeah you know what actually
when she asked me that I kind of I blew
it off I was like no you weren't here
yet I was waiting on the steps she said
that to me and I she asked me if I could
lead in her hell I said no and then she
said something about stuff going on in
the neighborhood Oh somebody was sitting
here I'm just trying to make sure and I
didn't I just let her say it
I was kind of stoned I was chilling
whatever you know set me off I'm
standing there on the back and then she
goes and takes a picture of my license
plate my youth is pouring raining it's
pouring
she went got wet to take a picture of
the license plate the Florida license
plate on my rented Mercedes what are you
and then I asked her I said was it worth
getting wet for this is what I kind of
flipped it was a word for getting wet
force you know I'm just trying to make
sure you know there was somebody sitting
on the porch stains somebody sitting on
the steps and what are you talking about
I'm just trying to pee I have a sieve
where I've been coming through here for
the past few years I've used as nosy as
you been now you would know that I'm
over here I'm just say just you know
what just just shut up and like you
taking fake officials and license plate
and [ __ ]
yeah she lives by herself she's a mom
not the best I can see why yeah I can
see why either somebody left or she just
made somebody so upset they died she's
old she's a lonely woman man you know
she's you need to get up Twitter um
she's just trying to make some human
some human contact
that's not no right wait I was walking
with purpose but you know what it is man
people that are lonely are usually
people that are the most concerned with
other people's business
yeah so you gotta give her that you know
like she's lonely
is it because if you're having a great
time and you're [ __ ] killing it and
you're doing your thing
you ain't worried about somebody walking
up some steps yeah whatever can I help
you what so what were you about to do
what answer what does he think I yeah
what did what does she think oh I know
this is getting intense for you guys so
we're gonna take a quick commercial
break while I get some money
Oh see geek I like see geek are you
seeing sometimes if I'm in some random
town and I want to go to the basketball
game and I want to get tickets last
minute I go to see geek give me some
seats to watch like a geek Oh gross I
also gonna see geek and check out how
much my scalp tickets I go on floor it's
a good toast I'll see all what they go
for
all somebody selling my tickets in
Cincinnati for $500 a pop very ambitious
they don't know the market well anyway
see geek of the app is a great
aggregator of all the third-party ticket
sales people in the world get cheap
tickets get a good deal they give you
deal rates get it
to get your $20 rebate on tickets down
the old the SeatGeek app go to the
settings tab and click add a promo code
into my promo code rambler see if you
can sing you $20 after you made your
first ticket purchase download the seat
geek app it's free and it's a promo code
Rambler our am bler today she's been
kicking it back here in the shot on a
break just got back to a couple dates
Baltimore was Lively great time in
Baltimore Baltimore all's done Baltimore
was interesting thoughts of what a good
vibe yeah in that in the Meyerhoff
Symphony Hall there's a good energy in
Baltimore only jokes that didn't go well
with my new my new Tony Robbins jokes
that I tried to do why didn't wait they
just Baltimore wasn't feeling the Tony
Robbins joke I don't know if they knew
just sorting that there yet this is my
first time trying but I haven't tried
him in a comedy club or anything I just
was excited about him and wanted to see
how they work and they weren't there yet
I think they need some they need a
little tinkering so ya been on the road
man Baltimore was live Richmond was fun
was supposed to have a good time in
Richmond I stayed an extra day in
Richmond
just chill and that's right what did you
how was that because you know I was
surprised by Richmond I didn't think it
was funny too because I saw this
magazine in my hotel room that said
Richmond is this the new Austin oh
really
yeah got a good energy in Richmond man
there was uh it was a little artsy as
you little jerk yeah it was a good was
surprising I didn't get to hang out with
a how many people in but let's just say
in Richmond my Instagram dibs were a
flight or he can go his I kicked it
there extra day it was raining most of
that day though and found out Steve Agee
was in the same hotel he was filming
something down there
Steve Agee community it was on Sarah
Silverman show
he played him and Brian Posehn with date
ran into him and grab some food talk
some talk and on the way there I had
walked past it because it was Richmond
Folk Festival which is a big musical
festival for the city and so there's
lots of events going on around us and on
the way to the restaurant I walked past
his clothing store but they had bands or
DJs going on in there doesn't that'll be
cool that'll be fun to check out after
dinner we have dinner say Steve let's go
check this out man
and we walk in you know like me whatever
fifty people something like that in
there and it's decent so I'm standing
there twenty speak to me at all welcome
and then some dude is super hyper have a
lot of props and then the whole party
kind of turned around and looked at me
it was the most uncomfortable thing I've
had it was you know people speak or I've
been as much like everybody stop what
they were doing everybody kind of hurt
because it was people the people facing
the music and then a huge where people
kind of just turned around and just
looking at me
it made me super I was that sounds like
some [ __ ] in the nightmare we just like
huh I'm like it was almost you know you
know those bits with people the scenes
with people walk into a bar and the
music cuts off but it was it was like
that everybody was just looking at me
and it was just I had never been in it
was the most like the drums just kind of
fall out and then the guitar goes yeah
I was so oh you know it was just so what
did you do you just can't I was a thing
I talked a few people came up and talked
to me and then some people asked for
pizzas but I didn't because I could see
what I was gonna go and I genuinely
wanted to see the music but I just
dipped out if this was that
uncomfortable I really use it yeah you
guys settle down and it was no it was a
clothing store so there was no bar to
dip to it was no it was super it's like
I noticed it's like a snowball effect to
what the pictures like cuz you be will
be at a spot chilling and then everybody
try to keep it cool and then once they
see you take one picture then you got
like just 20-30 years old I think
although people don't usually vision
recognize they don't clock me right away
because I look regular [ __ ] one time i
but is this certain spots
you don't realize where you can't go
until you go there sometimes you know
what I mean yeah yeah yeah where certain
spots you know a dive bar you go
somewhere
yeah sitting or happy what happens you'd
be able to do in Savannah we filming
Baywatch I kicked it at a couple spots
during off days that I sort of liked
while I was there and uh Zac Efron
yeah we are at dinner Zac elfenesh and
John a group of a decent group of us and
let's check out this bar Savannah
Hughes college town
so we pop it despite this one spot and I
tell you shakes just warm Zac Ephron and
it was that it was just a different oh
[ __ ] I felt like an [ __ ] cuz I
suggested that spot hey we left out of
there he had to run to his car and it
was a block and a half away six with
chasing why him down the street and I
said oh [ __ ] my bad I didn't I mean is
that girl front he's handsome guy I mean
it's gonna have big movie star but that
was I've never seen that before chicks
chasing ya going you know chasing him
that's next level man yeah it was yeah
can't go to that spot that's gotta suck
to just not be able to kick it it just a
random dive bar because people are
chasing you it's like it's like you're
you're wanted by the government or
something people are always chasing you
around yeah
DC let's start at DC tell me about DC
well DC I I get his email on let's say
September 29th September 30th asking if
I wanted to be a part of this South by
South Lawn event at the White House on
the White House lawn and so I'm reading
White House lawn on these VR
installations tech stuff the White House
bringing these ideas together and Obama
be there and these bands I'm performing
and I'm thinking at first cuz I just
skimmed the email I'm thinking I'm
getting invited to perform on the White
House lawn no it's not the case I'm
excited about it too I was misled I was
misled by
so the email clearly said that I'll be
performing at the after-party at the W
across the street yeah
but the the event was cool got to be on
the White House lawn we ran into a
couple people I've seen before
saw black girls code there they had this
cool installation where you try to get a
computerized ball to go through a maze
and it was fun I was on adderall so I
got kind of focused on it and then I let
it go after about three four minutes cuz
I didn't want to monopolize anybody
else's experiences wait that's not how
to say that right you know what I mean I
didn't want to just keep that [ __ ] and
keep people from doing it just because I
was enjoying myself so I stepped off saw
some VR stuff it's a long day it's
thinking we got there about two o'clock
1:30 no drinks I wasn't drinking that
day anyways but I can see why people
upset about no but you can't you can't
Obama can just have a couple thousand
people drinking on the White House lawn
you can have a little bit of soil types
you got nervous type people nervous are
they on the lawn anyways so people gonna
over drink to deal with the anxiety and
then you got a bunch of drunk weirdos
online you can't catch somebody vomited
on Secret Service shoes that's why you
invite responsible pee you don't you
know you yeah you can't trust everybody
to be responsible they drinking on the
White House lawn people get so hyped up
anyways so it's a long day
you know I saw the stuff I want to see
probably within an hour now that is all
it's five hours until Obama comes up so
I was staying coming man that's a long
time I don't know if this event really
has what it takes to hold me for five
hours but then maybe I should leave no
because there's no in and outs can't no
in and outs at the White House long
chorus part can just dip in bounce
not so you there and I was thinking
about it but I haven't seen the
president live before you know I saw
Iran it's a Rembert Brown great
journalist and we were talking about it
who leaves early you can't leave early
and mr. president that's just trying to
be too cool for school you're right what
was I thinking
what was I gonna do anyways at 7:30 in
DC something involving an internet room
service I don't think I could have
topped it 7:30 in DC I don't think I
could atop watching the president Tony
trim on the other hand so eat shrimp you
gotta bring this up man
Tony Tran and leaves early apparently to
go work on the teaser for this very
podcast the 60-second audio file didn't
go through when we sent it earlier and
so the they were bug and Tony about it
and so yeah I gotta leave all right
I was making a stand like Colin
Kapernick it's not a stand man no I will
not nobody justices of this event the
president speaking with the Nigel
DiCaprio you you left it like five is to
the bomb was at seven some you left that
five ish to go work on an audio file I
just take my job very seriously now I
mean you hired you hire the right person
listen man this is the first podcast and
this is coming in later than anybody
wanted it but you know what it's
sometimes you gotta just figure out the
right answer erase from what to talk
about
anyways Obama I digress Obama here's the
stage with Leonardo DiCaprio and another
person to talk about climate change then
they were talking it was a panel
this one was very well informed and
Obama kept referring her to her as a
Kathryn and I remember reading the the
program before looking online this is
president's doctor then why isn't he
saying doctor last name why I think why
keep calling her Kathryn I wouldn't he
say doctor maybe here's my theory you
may be wrong that doctor's full name is
dr. Kathryn
hey-ho and I feel like Obama didn't
wanna be recorded saying
hey-ho over and over that's what I think
Stu only has a few more months left in
the presidency it's not going on in his
on his goodbye tour he's not gonna let
CNN have video of him saying hey ho dr.
Hayhoe over here has a lot all the
research did dr. hey-ho hey-ho hey-ho
there's no way I hope there's no way to
say it yeah it doesn't sound offensive
that's a very unfortunate hey-ho
she probably married into it I wonder if
that's her name what she married hey all
the way is very unfortunate doctor hey
you think she would have married and
took a heigh-ho I think if anything she
would get married to get rid of hey ho
oh no man that's irrelevant but you know
what that also it had to Oh
at what point did hole become a part of
the vernacular cuz it hasn't it hasn't
been sincere
it's just he was born it was why she was
a teenager that wasn't a case they would
just talk about you know their neighbors
but all you had a hey hose over there
the Halos it was said but there is just
four horrors basically right house
[ __ ] I know
I came from I think no yes or for [ __ ]
yeah but when it that really hit I feel
like that hit in the seventies of some
probably back then when when tram was
still poppin so trim sure like have you
apply have you heavy patent
have you ever has you're like you're
older like your uncle's ever say that to
you like you out there getting some trim
like I love when people say that it's
just yeah one time I would set a party
there would be these stripper parties
yeah sometimes eight on the west side we
somebody have a house or an apartment
mmm and then they would have these they
hire a bunch of strippers and it'd be
kind of like an underground strip club
and so you know bunch of guys come
through people got their singles you
know sometimes maybe one of the dancers
houses they put it together sometimes a
random promoter and this is the
underground stripped it's a party that's
drinks you know people could dip into a
side room and do whatever and uh I
remember I went someone I went to a
couple of these when I was a teenager
and I'm gonna put who I was with high
school years I was in high school even
in high school of my freshman year of
college I think it might have been this
might have been my freshman year at
college that I went to this work okay so
it's doing seventeen years I was 70 80
and
to to to cats I was with one of them I
think the party got broken up well you
know everybody got kicked out something
happened and the host kicked everybody
out
uh-huh person I was with we get outside
the party and they open a jacket and I
took all the CDs okay well did you get
some good CDs I don't remember man I
just remember being shocked yeah that
this dude just took all the time I had
you seen these tells what am i it was a
cousin's friend you just took all the
CDs holy [ __ ] and so ever since then
whenever I go to somebody's house I
steal something significant and now I
still - I still all the time now there's
nobody suspects me of stealing like what
nobody thinks I'm stealing you don't
steal it wasn't man you don't know of
course exactly exactly
of course I don't steal you're right I
don't steal I would never steal why
would I steal that'd be stupid to steal
from my friends did welcomed me into
their home's
why would I do such a thing stealing was
fine when I was into it though stealing
was I everything every boy rush yeah
every boy went through to stealing hey
rush but then no rush you haven't been
caught I was caught and then I was like
it was a Walmart I was caught at a
Walmart and I was interrogated but I
didn't want a little stealing moves
where I like grab something and just
like walked out and it was like oh sorry
I thought I thought I'd pay for I forgot
to pay for it
kind of moves yeah also they did
interrogate told me I'm back rooms
interrogating me and you know this back
thing I was younger so I didn't have
ID'd asking for ID Dean call my parents
and I'm just like like no no no it's
like but they were bluffing they weren't
gonna call the cops so he just kind of
sat there back and forth who where you
live what's your phone number
I was like no they're like better not
come back here if I see you here I'll
call the cops and what was that and
after that I was like yeah man I won't
do that anymore
yeah but yeah I mean other than now I
would steal cigarettes cuz I couldn't
buy them but that was out of necessity
necessarily necessity but I'm saying
well yeah it used to man I used to be
into it like you used to steal straight
boo stuff deal that booth nothing of
significance nothing yeah I don't think
I ever stole something that had price
tag more than I $40 on it okay so you
never committed grand theft no I just I
just stole little things lots of times
woohoo candy yeah I was gonna say
candles oh we're being very excited
about still in a belt felt like you just
put it on the belt from Marshalls yeah
into Brickyard Marshalls was the easiest
to steal I was winning
I put a belt on yeah and then left just
left come on [ __ ] gonna get paid
enough to care you know there's just
like whatever yeah man
alright I remember people use I had a
homies that would go to the marshals and
litter
really going they're wearing like the
biggest bag is cloning they got and take
a bunch of stuff going to the changing
room throw it all on and then just walk
out looking like a snowman like no
problem
yeah Marshall is the easiest is deal for
ya I don't care about that merchandise
to me and my crew in high school we'll
go to it was Clark gas station right by
where my parents live and it was a
couple cashiers that didn't give a [ __ ]
about their jobs at all they didn't give
a [ __ ] or they didn't care about us
Dylan is that we can't control you know
cuz they buy a bulletproof glass anyway
so they got to either run behind from
behind there they got a cause but the
way what is this it's a tough tough
crime so you just go in there and clean
up Candy's juices sunglasses and it got
so crazy at one point we had a still in
contest we had a contest where we we all
went into the store stole as much as we
can and I made it in something and then
we all went back to my boy David's crib
mm-hmm and then we dog pull out what we
had to calculate the values which made
it up but would you calculate the value
like so this one item cost $20 so this
is way better I mean we had a just got
the price taxes oh yeah well there's
candy in [ __ ] yeah but I remember
who won that day it was his cat Kevin
yeah and Kevin won because he installed
a bunch of sunglasses and we were mostly
still it can't see us the cat yeah no
integrity at all still the sunglasses
9-volt batteries yeah
that's crap to do see
see some s EE s o is the new ad free
streaming service bringing you hilarious
original series him pick classics weeks
of stand-up specials and more every
single episode of Saturday Night Live
ever is on Cecil every episode ever you
can see the episode well I got my one
sketch on on the Charles Barkley episode
from 2010 season 35 the Barclays golf
sketch it's not that great but it's all
good man yeah British comedies you got
the original office on there the entire
money Python catalog the it crowd and
Steve Coogan as Alan Partridge yes
discover the next book names and
comedies and watch the icons before they
made it big like louis c.k Hannibal
Burres Chelsea for ready Amy Schumer Bo
Burnham is so many more I'm just reading
what they put down there I didn't write
this stuff see so is ad free and it is
just what 399 a month that's cheaper
than blank or the other one and it's
cheaper than the other one any other one
and right now my listeners try see so
for free for two months when you use
your promo code Rambla ramble oh that's
a fun word to say Rambla are a em be l e
RM la
Rambla checkout see SOCOM to significant
things happen yesterday yom kippur and
the Cubs won one against the San
Francisco Giants so it's very
significant de fer for me and Jewish
people you'll really insert a Cubs game
I was really into the car I mean it's
been an exciting season you yell so much
of the game I was wondering if you were
playing a character or if you are drugs
you've done it twice that's watching the
games you know I'm hyped like that at
the game no you keep it cool at the game
yeah well you know cuz I'm in my comfort
zone I'm around my friends so I could
just count a while out there at the game
yeah I'm good baseball guys good
baserunning I'm willing to say I'm a
bandwagon fan I'm a bandwagon fan man
guess what now Cubs doing I think I'm
into the nuances of baseball and I
haven't been before and it's stupid for
anybody to hate on this like yo this guy
enjoys watching a team win who doesn't
yeah it's great also they've been
winning a lot so I've been betting on
them most of the time and most of my
bets on the Cubs because they don't lose
that much there you go I think I may be
made throughout the season i wasn't
betting as much but throughout the
season maybe made 14 bets on the Cubs
and only maybe 3 lost i'm guessing so
thanks Cubs for helping me have a simple
stupid man's profitable baseball betting
season thank you so much to Theo thank
you to the Cubs organization I do how
crazy would it be White Sox Cubs World
Series that would be crazy
that would be insane that would be crazy
mm-hmm I want that in my life
you think that will happen in our
lifetime no no you think that happened
in my lifetime and not yours
cuz I'm getting it to some cryogenic
next level live forever type [ __ ] I'll
let you know the email that a guy if you
want to know okay said no [ __ ] oh you're
free you're being for real yeah you put
yourself in a chamber okay
you kind of I'm trying to go to 150 I
really want to see what they're doing
with video games by there is that wait
that's my main s a real thought of mine
is being seventy years old and wondering
how that year's version of NBA 2k is
gonna be how dope is 2k which means that
I'm not thinking great thoughts I'm not
using not using my brain power to its
maximum well maybe I am and that's what
I really want to think about is how good
video games will be 2017 because when
you're 70 what I mean 70 80
I guess our presidential candidates are
both pushing that with Trump 70
Hillary's about to turn 69 but 70 for me
in my head is just kind of chilling
maybe you have some great but you got to
think about the deeper issue with the
video games it's no longer gonna be
video games because he's getting so
close to virtual reality that by the
time we video games is morphing into a
different kind of reality it's becoming
this tool where you could like exercise
with it or you can like you can even
like try you could probably do
simulation training with it and stuff
it's like gonna go from video games to
straight-up virtual reality reality and
altering it so I don't even consider it
video games anymore it's gonna get to a
level where it's not even games like his
Nintendo it's not a little plumber
running around hitting bricks and
collecting coins you know what I'm
saying well no I virtual reality
definitely is it's becoming huge it so
what makes a video game you got rose on
a screen right yeah well that's what
you're gonna have a virtual reality you
have controls through the screen on your
face yeah
so still video games okay see I think
it's gonna go beyond that I think it's
gonna be like immersed reality were you
just like in this different world and
you can just go journey through jungles
and do crazy [ __ ] and that goes beyond
video game that goes into like you can
go so far but NBA 2k still have to be
those you could there's gotta be those
type of games where you are in this
world and you go through this stuff and
you swim and you do these actions and
such but some games are gonna kind of
still be she'll be [ __ ] in the face
you shooting or you got a press a button
so pass the ball or maybe move your hand
you're actually playing ball but there's
all five people so either you be at one
person or you controlling all five yeah
it was any fun play game with your
friends in a virtual or you could just
get a ball go to basketball court so
writers at the handsome rambling tell us
and a handsome Rambla the handsome
ramble at gmail.com tell us what do you
think video games are gonna be like 54
years from now mm-hmm
I'll be 87 in and by 87 I mean not
around here anymore all right
yeah oh it's ad time hey you're unique
you don't live life like anybody else
you don't walk around like anybody else
so why is your mattress for anybody else
because a custom truly a truly a truly
your unique you unique everybody's
different we're all different snowflakes
you don't walk like anybody else talk
like anybody else or sleep like
everybody else so why is your mattress
one size fits all because of truly
customized mattress now cost you five to
ten thousand bucks until now go to helix
sleep calm answer a few simple questions
and they'll run a 3d by a mechanical
model of your body do the proprietary
algorithms they develop with the help of
the world's largest her golden omits and
biomechanics experts the result the most
comfortable matches you've ever slept on
helix customers report a 30 percent
improvement in overall sleep quality and
for couples they customize each side of
the mattress your mattresses arrives at
your door in about a week and ship it is
a hundred percent free that's why
everyone from GQ magazine to Forbes
magazine are all talking about helix
sleep you have a hundred nights to try
it out if you don't love it they'll pick
it up for free and give you a hundred
percent refund no questions asked I mean
a little stain no questions asked about
that stain go to helix sleep comm slash
Rambler and get $50 off your order
that's helix sleep comm slash Rambler
helix sleep dot-com
slash bramble oh you want to get into
some questions we got a lot of new
questions really yeah okay this this
gives them okay answering questions from
the readers okay here we go
this one's from Shane Parker this is
what I'm Hannibal it's like to have you
in my weekly podcast rotation
congratulations on the podcasts thank
you thanks thanks now here's my question
my wife and I recently found out that I
cannot pregnant impregnate her because I
am sterile uh-oh we are both 33 and
we're planning on having kids soon we
were devastated we broke the news to my
parents and a few days later having
dinner with them my dad said that he'd
offer his sperm for my wife so that we
can have a kid with both of our genes
then he winked and said we can do it the
fun way if you want and licked his lips
I'm disgusted by I'm disgusted by my dad
my wife is B I'm disgusted by my dad and
my wife is beyond creeped out my dad is
74 and has never said anything creepy
like this I don't know what to do or if
we should consider taking him up on the
offer or if that would make my make my
kid my sibling what do you think thanks
Hannibal Shan that's a way that the the
details make it canon the subject says
advice on dad being creepy to my wife
that's crazy
yeah
he's sterile his dad offered his sperm
sees what I would wonder I'm no
biologist I'm no urologist I'm no OBGYN
but this old dude sperm look different I
mean this farm is part man the sperm is
there the sperm works is where I bought
the woman you know what I'm saying okay
that's what I'm just going off design is
obviously no scientific basic basis
there's no scientific racism what I'm
saying yeah just you know this old ass
dude but I guess it doesn't matter what
we get that's weird that he said that
but that's I mean esse we could do it
the fun way if you what it's a pretty
good joke this is a we cause this is Bob
I mean if he said that you know
depending on the spot which he said that
there and what was said right before it
if it was right in the floor
conversation if he just came up with
that off the top is pretty amazing joke
maybe been waiting for that moment for
what yeah yeah he said my dad at 74 has
never said anything creepy like this hey
he saw an opportunity for yeah anything
you know what you need the prostitutes
at his world yeah he's gonna bring
another you and cities a world I think
you're absolutely right Hannibal I think
that he needs to appreciate his dad's
sense of humor some years that even
bothers oh I think that I think here
Annette had
kind of thinking now man this my dad I
mean you know you asked for your dad's
help for some stuff hey Dad what's up
how do I fix his car right dad what do i
what I say dad I'm at the bank
what does I ask for mortgage rate or dad
I think I called my dad yesterday cuz
I'm getting floors I'm getting quotes on
carpeting or floors yeah foot a foot a
bill did you know instantly what are
they supposed to charge me and I told
him to quote he said if it's right
around there that sounds that sounds
about fair yeah cuz I don't know [ __ ]
about that advice yeah it floors and
carpet yeah
no haven't you dad [ __ ] you woman to
try to create another you you know but
here's the thing he's 74 so he's got
died so so he doesn't have to hear about
it for a while yeah but he brings up
another good point he says he's like I I
don't think I don't know what to do or
if we should consider taking him up on
the offer or if that would make my kid
my sibling because that is a good point
because yeah technically that's your bro
your wife is giving birth to your
brother your son and your brother yeah
man I say no I say don't do it I'd say
just do Z this is how much people this
is how much we answer ourselves man yes
got to create something from this gene
pool yeah gotta keep this bloodline yeah
yeah not even considered adopted you
know you first started reading the
letter and he said he was sterile I
thought he was right and asking me to
impregnate his wife
[Laughter]
the handsome Rev Loretta gmail.com if
you want me to get your wife or
significant other pregnant I'll do it
hit my agent would I do that do that I
would if it was a friend in need I would
do it I would but here's the thing coz
though you got I mean you gotta hit
those days those particular ovulation
days cuz you that's what that you can oh
if your friend is asking you I'd be
honored you be on it but you got it you
don't always happen the first time yeah
so you have to have screens you know
things just just an innate girl
oh I mean over and over again yeah so
you'd up the jizan or over and over and
it will probably take a few attend take
a few tips yeah I think most people will
opt to they will pay to make that to
have it done unnaturally and inseminate
it versus the future baggage that could
accompany having one of your friends
leave it in with the love of your life
yeah man I don't know what to say that
that's such a tough situation so that's
a rough joke it's a good joke it didn't
need to be said it's not a necessary
joke it's a great joke
I respect I respected but also as his
pops kinda that's 70s no II just no
[ __ ] given at this point it's not no
fuzz gave it it's not that it's beyond
that being an old man I think part of it
a big part of manhood is virility and
have any ability
to help produce children and keep the
species gone well and so his dad is kind
of kind of big-time done you know mm-hmm
the a out I'll [ __ ] you I'll [ __ ] your
wife for you says you can't little boy
you see I'll bring some news that we
could do it the fun way I'll bring some
new life
what is his mom's alive was his mom
there oh I have no I mean they didn't
put that part yeah oh if the mom was
there and he made that joke oh she
wouldn't be having that he didn't
mention the mom no the mom he did
investor the mom big part of it you can
say my mom is a part of the equation
yeah or maybe they ain't together
because you know moms want to stuff than
ever like also probably a weird combo
for mom to be a part of anyway yeah yeah
yeah exactly I don't know man I say man
there's plenty of people to adopt in
this world and just go adopt adopt the
child adopted is is really nice and it's
a noble thing to do and you're helping
Society and you're helping Society it's
a super noble thing good for your taxes
but also I get the thing of one star
from scratch yeah you know some people
want there's you know then what this
brand new straight out the box all right
well that was the first episode you
gonna figure it out I'm thinking about
what if I did a podcast what if I when I
was traveling and I set up I went on
tinder
and then set up a time in place for
tinder date to meet and then they showed
up in the same welcome to my park is
maybe I do have for the next I think we
should do that anyways this has been the
first episode of the handsome Brambilla
thank you all for listening go to
Hannibal Burres calm / tour I'm on the
road see me in your city I think I'm
coming to Rosa Victoria British Columbia
Calgary DC NYC coming up Rhode Island so
check me out this was fun I'm here
[Music]